in another video we've already talked
about what an opposite of a number is
but we'll review it a little bit if we
start with a positive number say the
number for if you have a if you have a
number if you have a number and then we
want to think about what the opposite of
that number is opposite this is just a
symbol for number or shorthand for
number so if the number is four what is
its opposite well four is one two three
four to the right of zero positive four
is four to the right of zero so it's
opposite is going to be one two three
four to the left so it's going to be
negative four or another way to think
about it if you have a positive number
its opposite is going to be the negative
of that number so another way of
thinking about it is is that this
negative literally means opposite one
way to think about it this is the number
that is the opposite of four so let me
write this down
so if I write negative negative four
negative let me write this negative
negative four that literally means that
literally means so you you can take this
negative symbol as meaning opposite
opposite opposite of four opposite of
four if you were to say if you were to
say negative instead of saying a
specific number let's just say a letter
that could represent a number so if I
said negative a that means the opposite
of the number a that means the opposite
that means the opposite opposite of
opposite let me do that blue color
opposite of a of a and if this confuses
you a little bit just look a could be
any number right over here so let me
draw a number line just so this can be a
little bit make a little bit more sense
hopefully so this is a number line and
let's say let me put some tick marks
here and I don't know how much each of
these tick marks jump but let's say that
a is some number that is right right
over here
well negative a is going to be the
opposite of
a so if a is three tick marks to the
right negative a is going to be three
tick marks to the left one two three and
so the opposite of a is going to be this
value right over here and we can write
that we could write opposite of a over
here we could literally write opposite
opposite of a is that number right over
there or as a shorthand as a shorthand
we can just write we can just write
negative we can just write this is
negative a right over here negative
negative a so with that in mind if we
literally view this negative symbol as
meaning the opposite of whatever this is
let's try something interesting what
would be the negative let me do this in
another color let me do this what would
be the negative of negative three
encourage you to pause the video and
think about it what we just said this
negative means the opposite so you can
think about this as meaning this means
the opposite opposite of opposite of
negative the opposite of negative three
so what's the opposite of negative three
well negative three is three to the left
of zero one two three so it's opposite
is going to be three to the right of
zero one two three so it's going to be
positive three so this is equal to this
is equal to positive three or we could
just write positive three like positive
three like that so hopefully this gives
you a better appreciation for what
opposite means and also how it relates
to the actual the actual negative symbol
and we could keep going you know we
could we could do something like what is
what is the negative of the negative of
negative let me do a different number of
negative two well this part right over
here the negative the opposite
of negative 2 which is really the
opposite of the opposite of 2 well
that's just going to be - every time you
say opposite you flip over the you flip
over the number line so this flips you
over the number line 2 to the left and
then this flips you back to to the right
so all this is going to be 2 but then
you're going to take the opposite of 2
so that's just going to be negative
that's going to be negative 2 if you
threw another negative in front of this
would be the opposite of all of this
would be the opposite of negative 2 and
then no son would become positive so
every time you put that negative in
front there you're flipping on the other
side of the number line